you have this reputation now in your own
district and nationally as the guy who's
willing to make the meme or you know do
make take the unpopular vote um and I
think the one of the Prime examples of
that is back in the the depths of covid
March
2020 everyone was pushing for this $2.2
trillion covid relief bill including the
president of the United States and it
was representative Thomas Massie who was
saying if we're going to have a million2
trillion vote here let's follow the
Constitution and have everyone come back
to DC and actually do it in person and
for that going back to Twitter the uh or
you know now X the kind of locust of
political discourse president Trump's
response to that was look like looks
like a third rate grandstander named
representative Thomas Massie a
congressman from unfortunately a truly
great state Kentucky wants to vote
against the new Save Our Workers Bill in
Congress he just wants the publicity he
can't stop it uh he goes on to say that
uh you know the Republicans should win
the house but they should kick out uh
Thomas Massie I mean what was that like
having the eye of Sauron on you for
insisting on an in-person vote in March
2020 oh well I'll have to write a book
someday but that those tweets happened
about 60 seconds after a phone call
ended between me and president Trump
where um he basically burned my ear off
screaming at me for probably three
minutes and said he was coming at me he
was going to take me down and um that's
a sobering proposition when you're
you've got a primary election eight
weeks away you've been trying to keep
the president out of your race the
person running against you says you
don't support the president enough
enough and the president had 95%
approval rating among the primary voters
who were going to vote in my election
but um I just stood strong I said listen
if if truckers and nurses and grocery
store workers are showing up for work
then Congress should show up for work
too and that was I think an unassailable
message because ultimately I was just
trying to get people on record the
reason I was trying to get people on
record is I knew that was one of the
worst votes in history and nobody was
going to be accountable for it um and so
I'm you know here we are three years
later every bad thing that I said would
happen as a result of of doing that has
happened and even my colleagues here in
Congress a lot of them admit to me um
that they were wrong about that they
won't say it too loudly lest anybody
hear it and I got 81% in that primary
you know know with Trump screaming at me
and and tweeting at me and whatnot by
the way the the reporters came up to me
as I walked out of the chamber that day
and said your own president just called
you a third rate grandstander what do
you have to say and I said I was deeply
insulted I'm at least second rate um and
they didn't have a come back to that but
be
careful if you ask the um the
ex uh chatbot or whatever you know the
AI that Elon Musk has on if you ask it
to roast me it will say that I you know
like a washed up high school quarterback
I like to talk about that one event back
on March 27th 2020 too much and you know
it's kind of funny that it roasts me for
bringing that up so you if x is
listening if grock is listening I wanted
to know that you Zach brought it up not
me yes yeah how much Co policy remorse
is there among your colleagues in
Congress not enough not nearly enough um
there should be the policy isn't just
the spending the vaccine mandates the
the shutting down of our
economy uh the the compulsory masking
the way people were treated like cattle
there should be far more
remorse um but frankly that's a
reflection of the voters as well if you
poll this most people have moved on even
a year ago most people people have moved
had moved on and it wasn't in the top
five issues of what people care about in
any congressional district you can't
campaign on well I tried to save you
during covid I mean look at um Ron de
santis that was part of his signature
issue and by being the you know
different Governors responded
differently but he most famously opposed
A lot of this covid nonsense after it
became obvious is what we were dealing
with and um he rode that wave and he was
polling better than Trump but I think
people have moved on and they've got
other issues to think about now and um
that's you know people have just moved
on and so have my colleagues and I think
it's really unfortunate and I wished
that I had been able to get that
recorded vote that day we'd have a lot
more people who wouldn't be back here in
Congress perpetrating bad ideas like
fisa so I have one last question um and
then we'll wrap up because I know you
have other stuff to get to uh you're a
busy man but on that topic you know one
of the things that the cares act and
that the pandemic stimulus spending led
to um you know at least as far as I can
tell is inflation right like that's
something that's on American voters
Minds do you see any signs and also you
were elected during sort of the era of
the tea party you know reigning in
government spending a sense of well we
care about about our fiscal health and
so as a result we can't just have the
money printer constantly print money
forever more we have to be prudent uh
because the bill always comes due do you
think that that message has any hopes of
having any sort of Revival in the coming
years especially given the runaway
inflation that we've seen or do you
think it's just a totally lost cause and
we're all
screwed let me assign a 95% probability
to that last proposition
but but I'm I'm here in the 5% chance
that that we can save it and in the 30%
chance that if it all goes to hell in a
hand basket I can still be here and have
some credibility and putting it back
together um I think what's starting to
curb the appetite for spending and bring
some realism into the discussion is is
the only thing that was ever going to
curb our appetite for spending and that
is our creditor
are starting to B um the the rates at
which the government can borrow money
now aren't what we want them to be when
we go out to do an auction or a sale for
treasuries or or bonds what we're
finding is the appetite isn't there even
at four and a half percent you know to
get guaranteed 4 and a half% return on
your money you know from the government
back by the US military that's not
enough to to loan that money to the
government they want 5% that's an
indicator that you know when the private
sector and and the other countries Who
The Sovereign you know funds who usually
uh have the appetite for our debt when
they're losing their appetite that's a
sign that things are going south and um
not not to promote it too much because
grock roasts me for this too but I wear
this debt clock that I built um in in
Congress to remind people of it and one
side effect of me wearing this is I've
noted I've noticed that because it by
the way it logs on to treasury's website
once a day gets the debt to the penny it
would do it more frequently but they
only publish it once a day as a
consequence of wearing this and looking
at it every day one thing I've noticed
is the rate at which the debt is
increasing is going up
so that like the for the math nerds
that's the second derivative and today
the debt per second is set averaged over
the last year
$78,000 a
second it's just I don't think people
realize it feels like we're going over
Niagara Falls right now to me hey thanks
for watching that clip from our new show
just asking questions you can watch
another clip here or the full episode
here new episodes every week so
subscribe to recent TV's YouTube channel
to get notified when that happens or to
the just asking questions podcast on
Apple Spotify or any other podcaster see
you next week